وتنضم الينا من كابول سحر اكبر الطالب
الجامعيه في كليه الاعلام سنه رابعه
ونهائيه اهلا بك سحر يعني انتي بالسنه
الاخيره يعني قبل التخرج اخبرينا عن لحظه
ابلاغك بهذا القرار من قبل طلبان اين كنت
وهل كان متوقعا هذا القرار
همم صلاه احترام خدمات الزوج
[موسيقى]
واقول ان اليوم كان يوما مؤسفا بالنسبه
لنا نحن النساء همم اللواتي تطهد حقوقنا
في داخل البلاد حق الخروج من المنزل اليوم
اخر الحقوق كان حق التعليم الذي سلب من
هؤلاء همم يعني حطوا من قلوب البنات
والفتيات
والنساءات جدا
وحق التعليم هو حق اساسي همم
المراه في مجتمعنا وهذا مؤلم جدا في
الحقيقه بالنسبه همم لنا همم لكل من يتابع
الاوضاع في افغانستان طيب سحر يعني انت
هذه هي السنه الاخيره كام مثل ما ذكرنا ما
هي يعني ماذا ستفعلين يعني انت كنت
ستتخرجين من الجامعه لتعملي لاحقا ما
مخططاتك هلك القدره ربما على الانتقال الى
بلد اخر
ماذا تفعل الفتاه الافغانيه في هكذا حالات
قبول النظافه
لن نسكت عن هذا
لانه اذا تم منع المجتمع الافغاني ونصف
المجتمع النساء من حق التعليم واا
رسم مستقبلهم انا همم مثلا في السنه
الاخيره همم كنت ادرس في الصحافه مثل
الكثيرات يدرسنا في الطب وفي التعليم وفي
مختلف الفروع التي تحتاجها المجتمع يجب ان
نفهم
السلطات ان همم الفتيات من التعليم سيؤدي
الى تدهور الى وضع اكثر ولا يساعد في
الاستقرار
كانها مش تمام
لكي يتضامن مع المجتمع الافغاني
والمجتمع الافغاني لا يستحق كل هذا التعسف
والظل سحر كلمه اخيره توجهها
لحركه طالبان وللعالم
ماذا تقول له
ده الكلام
التي تسمع صوت النساء الافغانيات ان يهبوا
لنجدتنا لانه لا احد يسمع صوتنا في داخل
الاضغانستان نحن نشعر باننا وحيدون اذا
كنا نحن مواطنات تبغانيات فيجب ان يتم
الاعتراف بحقوقنا نطالب اللي هو المتحده
وكل المجتمع الدولي ان يحترموا حقوقنا
ويضغطوا على السلطات كي تلغي هذا القرار
المجحف وايضا همم
ونقول لهم همم دعونا نضع يدا وان نبني
بلدنا بدل تهميش النساء الافغانيات ونحترم
حقوق جميع فئات المجتمع لان هؤلاء البنات
هم البنات
ايضا الله لم يخلق احد لكي ااه يطهد همم
الناس بني جبتهم
ويجب ان تكون المحبه هي التي تسود بيننا
وليس اضطهاد بعضنا البعض الاخر شكرا جزيلا
لك سحر اكبر الطالبه الجامعيه في كليه
الاعلام سن الرابعه